>> Jon: WELCOME BACK! THIS
MORNING, THIS MORNING,
THIS VERY MORNING WE GOT WORD OF
A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> KENTUCKY SENATOR RAND PAUL
BECOMING THE SECOND REPUBLICAN
TO OFFICIALLY JOIN THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
HE HAS SCHEDULED AN EVENT TODAY
IN LOUISVILLE.
>> Jon: OH, MY GOD, OH, MY GOD,
OH, MY GOD.
AH, WE KNEW HE WAS GOING TO
RUN.
ANYWAY, COULD BE SOMETHING.
A NONDOCTRINAIRE REPUBLICAN,
STRONG LIBERTARIAN
BENT OFFERING AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THE BUSH AND CLINTON
PRESIDENTIAL DYNASTIES.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO
THE BIG ANNOUNCEMENT?
>> THIS IS THE START OF A CAUSE,
A CAUSE TO ELECT RAND PAUL AS
THE NEXT UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Jon: NOW I KNEW THAT RAND
PAUL HAD SOME UNCONVENTIONAL
IDEAS, BUT ELECTING HIM THE
NEXT UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
IS I THINK, -- I THINK IT'S --
WE GET THE POINT, THOUGH.
LET'S HEAR FROM THE MAN HIMSELF.
SENATOR RAND PAUL!
>> WE'RE GONNA ASK J.D. WILLIAMS
TO COME UP AND LEAD US IN
OUR PLEDGE.
>> Jon: RIGHT NO, YOU HAVE TO DO
THE PLEDGE FIRST. OF COURSE.
THAT'S -- HOW ELSE DO YOU SMOKE
OUT THE TRAITORS?
ALL RIGHT, WE DO THE PLEDGE.
BUT NOW, THE KENTUCKIAN, RAND
PAUL!
>> PASTOR JERRY STEPHENSON WILL
NOW GIVE US OUR INVOCATION.
NEXT I WANT TO INTRODUCE RALPH
ALVARADO.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
WELCOME KELLEY PAUL.
>> PLEASE WELCOME LAUREN
BOSLER.
>> YOU ARE IN FOR A REAL TREAT
AS I ASKED MARLANA VANHOOSE
TO COME AND SING THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM.
>> ♪
♪ AND THE HOME OF THE AND THE
HOME OF THE BRAVE!  ♪
♪
>> Jon: HOLY (BLEEP), THAT KID
HAS PIPES.
THAT KID WAS AMAZING.
I'VE GOT TO SAY IF THIS WHOLE
PRESIDENT THING DOESN'T WORK
OUT, RAND PAUL HAS A FUTURE AS
THE NEXT PRODUCER OF THE OSCARS.
I MEAN, TALK ABOUT PUTTING ON A
SHOW, ON TOP OF ALL THOSE
SPECIAL GUESTS, THIS GUY CAME
ARMED WITH FOUR, YES FOUR,
SEPARATE VIDEO PACKAGES. THERE
WAS ONE ON INTERNET PRIVACY,
THERE WAS ONE ON URBAN POVERTY.
30 MINUTES INTO THE SHOW,
I HAD SAID MORE AT THIS EVENT
THAN THE GUY WHO WAS
THERE TO ANNOUNCE HIS CANDIDACY
FOR PRESIDENT.
THERE WAS EVEN A VIDEO ABOUT
RAND PAUL'S HARRY MET SALLY
MOMENT WITH HIS FUTURE WIFE WHEN
THEY MET.
>> I MET HIM ON A
BEAUTIFUL SPRING DAY.
HE WAS A CUTE
CURLY HEADED GUY.
I ALSO THOUGHT HE WAS PROBABLY
18 YEARS OLD AND STILL IN
COLLEGE, I REALIZED THAT HE WAS
NOT 18, HE WAS 26.
>> Jon: AND I REMEMBER SAYING
TO HIM, 26?
AND YOU ARE STILL A
LIBERTARIAN?
AND THEN FINALLY, A LONG SLOW
HOUR AFTER POST TIME.
>> PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
MY HUSBAND AND YOUR AWESOME U.S.
SENATOR, RAND PAUL.
>> FINALLY! AT THIS POINT EVEN
HILLARY CLINTON WAS LIKE JUST
ANNOUNCE ALREADY, PLEASE.
>> WITH YOUR HELP, THIS MESSAGE
WILL RING FROM COAST TO COAST.
A MESSAGE OF LIBERTY, JUSTICE
AND PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
TODAY BEGINS THE JOURNEY TO TAKE
AMERICA BACK.
>> Jon: HULK -- HULK ANGRY.
HULK ANGRY AT OVERWHELMING
GOVERNMENT SURVEILLANCE
STATE.
HULK WANT AUDIT THE FED.
YOU TEED IT UP, RAND. BRING IT
HOME, BABY.
>> TODAY, I ANNOUNCE WITH GOD'S
HELP, WITH THE HELP OF LIBERTY
LOVERS EVERYWHERE, THAT I AM
PUTTING MYSELF FORWARD AS A
CANDIDATE FOR --
>> Jon: OH, I'M SORRY.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.